- Did FTX have sufficient
risk management systems
and controls to appropriately
monitor any leverage
the business took on and
the interconnections it had
with businesses like, again, Alameda?
- There were virtually
no internal controls
and no separateness whatsoever.
- So what is the big picture balance loss
as a result of this bankruptcy?
How much has FTX lost as a result of this?
- We don't have exact
numbers, but we know ballpark.
Several billion dollars, you
know, in excess of 7 billion.
- Can you provide some indication
of whether customer funds from FTX.com
were in fact transferred
to Alameda Research?
- Well, it's definitely assets
of customers in the .com silo
were transferred to Alameda,
no question about it.
We have not seen this at
this stage from the US silo
but of course, you know,
we do have one concern
and that's the concern we're chasing down,
which is whether or
not there's co-mingling
between that .com silo
and the US silo exchanges.
And the reason for that is we know
that there was sort of
common control and access
of authorized users at this
most senior management level
amongst all of the assets.
So it's something we have to focus on.
We haven't seen evidence right now of that
but certainly that's
something that we need
to investigate and trace.
- Are you yet in a position
to be able to describe,
summarize the assets
that Alameda had?
- We do have an inventory
of the investments we made.
That's pretty clear.
We've got those in the hands
of our investment bankers
at Perella and we're trying to
understand those investments.
Ultimately, we'll market
those investments.
You'll see this week that
some of those investments
will be put up for sale.
The crypto assets, a little bit different.
What's on the exchanges?
We can see.
There's exchanges, about
two dozen exchanges
across the world where we
know we have crypto assets.
They're in our name.
We're securing those
and we're moving those into cold storage.
We have, you know, other positions
in cold wallets and hot wallets.
We've got visibility to that.
The question really is
are there wallets that
we don't know about?
Certainly that is the potential
because the way this
company was organized,
there may be wallets that
don't have our names,
we don't know where they are,
and that's gonna be, you know,
a difficult task ahead of us.
But what we can see
and what we have visibility to,
we're grabbing control over.
- What are some
of the biggest questions you still have
for Mr. Bankman-Fried
and his associates now
that you've been through
this for some period?
- Look, I think the questions we have
are not necessarily
questions for Mr. Fried.
The questions we have are, you know,
where are the assets, how
do we locate those assets?
It's a mining exercise at this point.
And look, at the end of the day,
we're not gonna be able to
recover all the losses here.
Money was spent that we'll never get back.
There will be losses on
the international side.
We're hopeful on the US side.
He'll answer to others
related to what happened here.
Our job is just to, you
know, find the assets
and try to get customers their money back
as quickly as possible.